♪♪
Narrator: KARI, GRANT, AND TORY
ARE TACKLING THE TALL TALE
THAT A TRANCE IS YOUR CHANCE
FOR A HOT-COAL CROSSING.
YEAH!
SEE?
THAT WASN'T SO BAD.
BUT SO FAR, THE NUMBERS PREDICT
THAT ANYONE CAN DO IT BURN-FREE.
HOWEVER, THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY
TO FIND OUT FOR SURE.
SO A HOP, STEP,
AND A JUMP CUT LATER...
DOES IT SEEM LIKE
A STUPID IDEA NOW?
NO.
WE'VE HAD A LOT STUPIDER IDEAS
THAN THIS.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: IT'S THE MOMENT WE,
IF NOT KARI, GRANT, AND TORY,
HAVE ALL BEEN WAITING FOR.
ALL RIGHT, THOSE COALS ARE
ALL RED HOT! YOU GUYS READY?
THERE'S NO TURNING BACK NOW.
[ GROANS ]
ARE YOU NERVOUS AT ALL?
NO.
MNH, A LITTLE.
[ SIGHS ] AAH!
Narrator: AFTER A FEW MOMENTS
TO PSYCH HERSELF UP,
KARI'S THE FIRST
ONTO THE FOOT FRYER.
CUE THE DRAMATIC MUSIC.
[ SOFT INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC
PLAYS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
[BLEEP]
IT'S NOT TOTALLY
NOT HOT.
DESPITE HER LEVELS OF ADRENALINE
SHOOTING OFF THE SCALE,
KARI MAKES IT ACROSS SAFELY
AND FINDS HER FEET UNFRIED.
IT'S DOABLE.
THAT'S DOABLE.
Narrator: NEXT UP FOR
THEIR TIPTOE INTO TREPIDATION
IS GRANT.
YEAH, GRANT!
AND COOL AS A CUCUMBER,
HE CATWALKS OVER THE COALS.
WHOO!
THERE WE GO.
A LITTLE HOT.
A LITTLE HOTTER THAN I EXPECTED,
BUT...I THINK I MADE IT.
Narrator:
WHICH JUST LEAVES TORY.
AND TRUE TO FORM, HE STEPS UP
AND CHARGES STRAIGHT IN...
HERE WE GO.
...BEFORE BREEZING ACROSS.
IT'S NOT THAT BAD AT ALL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE
A LOT WORSE THAN THAT.
IT LOOKS WAY WORSE THAN IT IS.
IT'S REALLY NOT THAT BAD.
IT'S THE MENTAL PART
THAT MESSES WITH YOU THE MOST.
AS SOON AS I STEPPED ON IT,
IT REALLY WASN'T THAT BAD.
IN FACT, I DIDN'T EVEN FEEL IT.
I HAD TO WALK BACK ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE HOT.
THAT WAS SO CRAZY,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE WORST PART WAS WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN YOUR HEAD.
THE PHYSICAL
WASN'T SO BAD.
YEAH, THERE IS NOT ANY AMOUNT
OF DRUMMING OR CHANTING
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE ME
WALK ON THAT COAL.
BUT THE PHYSICS --
THE PHYSICS WAS THERE.
THAT'S WHAT GOT ME THROUGH
THE FIRST STEP.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
IT WAS HOT OUT THERE,
BUT NOT HOT ENOUGH TO BURN US.
ALL RIGHT, SO THIS ONE'S
LOOKING BUSTED.
BUSTED.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TRY
GASOLINE-SOAKED SOCKS NEXT.
WHOO!
Narrator:
IT SEEMS IT'S PHYSICS
THAT KEEP YOUR FEET
FROM BEING FLAME-GRILLED,
AND NOT MIND OVER MATTER,
OR IS IT?
WHAT ABOUT A MIND UNPREPARED,
A MIND UNSULLIED
BY THE CERTAINTY OF SCIENCE?
I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE
A LOT WORSE THAN THAT.
Narrator: TO FIND OUT,
LET'S "SEGWAY" TO THE NEXT DAY.
WHAT ARE YOU COOKING?
WE'RE GONNA BE COOKING,
WELL, THE BOTTOM OF YOUR FEET.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SCIENCE
OF FIRE WALKING.
[ GASPS ]
FIRE WALKING! AWESOME!
Narrator: UH, APPARENTLY,
ADAM WOULD WALK OVER HOT COALS
TO WALK OVER HOT COALS.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'RE ALL SET UP,
ADAM JUST GOT HERE,
BUT WE HAVEN'T LIT THE FIRE YET.
I WANT TO LIGHT IT
IN FRONT OF HIM SO HE SEES
HOW HOT THIS FIRE GETS SO THAT
STARTS PLAYING ON HIS MIND.
♪♪
Adam: IT'S ONE THING TO
THINK INTELLECTUALLY
THAT I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO WALK ON FIRE.
IT'S QUITE ANOTHER TO FEEL THE
HEAT OF 2,000-SOME-ODD DEGREES
AT MY BACK.
Narrator: SO ADAM'S READY
FOR HIS TRIAL BY FIRE.
Tory:
YOU CAN DO IT!
AND REMEMBER,
BEFORE KARI, GRANT,
AND TORY
TOOK THEIR FIRST HOT STEP,
THEY KNEW
THEY WOULDN'T GET BURNED.
MY HEART RATE
JUST WENT UP A BIT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT ADAM KNOWS NOTHING
ABOUT THE DATA
AND THE TECHNIQUE
OF STEPPING LIGHTLY.
WILL HE GET ACROSS UNSCATHED,
OR WILL THOSE RED-HOT COALS
FRY HIS FEET?
AAH! [BLEEP]
[ LAUGHTER ]
AH, YES. APPARENTLY SO.
WHOO!
WOW!
THAT HURT A LOT.
Adam:
"OW" WAS GOING THROUGH MY HEAD.
AS I DID IT -- WALK, WALK, WALK,
"THIS ISN'T SO BAD.
"HOLY CRAP,
THIS IS PRETTY BAD.
AAH!" LIKE THAT.
THAT'S ABOUT
THE THOUGHT PROCESS.
Narrator: SO IT SEEMS THAT IT
DOES MATTER WHAT'S IN YOUR MIND.
BUT ONLY INSOFAR AS KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT TECHNIQUE
AND PREPARATION GO.
Adam: WITH NO PREP AT ALL,
I THINK I MADE A CLASSIC MISTAKE
OF SPEEDING UP AND DIGGING
MY FEET INTO THE COALS MORE.
AAH!
Narrator:
YEP, ADAM'S HARD-MARCHING METHOD
MEANT SOME OF THE COALS
STUCK TO HIS FEET,
GIVING THEM MORE TIME
TO CONDUCT THEIR HEAT.
AAH!